there appears to be no let up in the
battle for control of ukraine's eastern
industrial heartland the donbass but the
civilian toll is rising the regional
governor says at least four civilians
were killed in an air strike in the
eastern ukrainian city of luzichansk as
they sheltered at a cultural center it's
the latest city under ukrainian control
in the region after russia seized almost
full control of neighboring savira
donate next
with the russian campaign intensifying
in blizzard chang's canal people face a
difficult question of whether to leave
or stay
it's a gruesome task
rescue workers look for survivors under
the rubble at this cultural center in
lisiansk
they come across some of the victims
the building sheltering dozens of people
was destroyed in what the luhansk
regional governor says was a russian air
strike
eyewitnesses describe what happened
after the attack
i heard someone cry
terrible cries
i ran here and saw only ruins and bodies
they were carried away on stretchers
some were alive some were dead
lizzy chansk is just across the river
from sevilla donetsk the key
battleground in russia's latest
offensive in the donbass region
unlike his northern neighbor the city is
still under ukrainian control
but constant russian shelling and rocket
attacks mean the civilians here are in
grave danger authorities are trying to
convince them to leave but some refuse
we are old people we do not have a place
to go where will i go i'm 72
they will dump me in some village
somewhere
guys fight for peace let the peace come
many though decided to leave
it's believed less than a fifth of the
pre-war population of nearly one hundred
thousand people still remains in
lysichansk
for many of them destroyed houses mean
they can only seek shelter in basements
like this one
i don't know how to put it into words
people are afraid this is war it's scary
there's no communication you can't go
out anywhere there's no place to go
with nowhere to go and no end to the
fighting inside these people are praying
their lives shattered by the brutal
conflict will be spared
let's get an update now from our
correspondent roman gonciarenko he joins
us from ukraine's capital kiev roman
what's the latest on the fighting in
ukraine
well there is not much here much new uh
the fighting continues all along the
front line which is more than one
thousand kilometers long
um the most severe fighting is around
the city of sierra donetsk and we have
reports that the russians are attacking
from nine directions
there are still civilians at that
chemical plant are thought
we have new figures the ukrainians say
that there are some 568 civilians there
and 38
children
most of them are workers of that plant
and their families and they've been
staying there for a while um the
attempts to save them
to get them out failed yesterday and we
expect more attempts today or in the
coming days um russian rockets also hit
the ukrainian city of mikolai which is
in the south at black sea and
there are new reports from the ukrainian
armed forces that they
they claim to have hit a russian attack
boat
near the island the snake island which
is a strategically important island in
the black sea just south of odessa and
ukrainian forces say they hid that tag
boat which was carrying russian troops
now yesterday we saw some high
diplomacy in kiev the leaders of germany
france italy and romania traveled there
for face-to-face talks with ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky the visiting
leaders said they back ukraine's bid to
become an eu membership candidate and
they expressed their outrage at the
devastation wrought by russian forces in
ukraine let's take a look
in the ruins of kiev's suburb alpine
europe's leaders saw for themselves the
devastation of the war
the heads of france germany and italy
met with romania's president to tour the
suburb where heavy fighting and alleged
war crimes saw many civilians killed
their first visit to ukraine since
russia invaded was a chance to show
europe's support
and counter criticism over the speed and
scale of their
europe is by responses side
it will remain so for as long as
necessary until victory is achieved
in the form of a return to peace in a
free and independent ukraine
the opposite of the consequences of the
barbarism that we have seen together
this morning in urpin
in a joint press conference in kiev
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
called for more heavy weaponry
positioning his country as europe's
eastern flank
russia does not choose whom and when to
threaten
whom in europe to grant safety
russian aggression against ukraine is
aggression against all of europe
against the united europe
against every one of us
against our values
must be united
the european leaders pledged more
military aid and backed immediate
candidate status for ukraine joining the
european union
ukraine belongs within the european
family
and the milestone on its journey toward
the eu would be to receive candidate
status
the eu is set to discuss ukraine's
candidacy on friday but even if all
member states agree it could still take
years for keeve to gain actual
membership
so roman a show of solidarity there for
ukraine by the leaders of the four eu
countries uh was that as much as
vladimir zelinski could hope for or was
he expecting more
well the landscape himself said he was
satisfied i think he was pretty happy
with that support for the ukrainian eu
bid
uh maybe he was a bit disappointed that
there were no uh or very few new
commitments to to supply ukraine with
arms with heavy arms uh with artillery
in the first place
and i think he might have been
disappointed that there was um there
were no specific commitments uh as to
the sanctions new sanctions against
russia especially no new sanctions um
no embargo on russian gas which is which
would hit russia really hard and this is
something that ukraine is hoping for uh
but in general i think ukraine uh is
rather satisfied with the results of
that visit yes
if ukraine does formally become an eu
candidate country roman would that
change anything in the effort to end the
russian invasion
well this will not change
anything immediately on the battlefield
but we shouldn't underestimate it's an
extremely important
sign a sign of political support for
ukraine
it's a moral booster for the ukrainian
society which
has been hoping for that
chance to be to become an eu member for
for many decades for two decades
actually and um it's it's a historic
event and we've heard those words
historic yesterday during the press
conference several times but practically
speaking uh this will give ukraine more
money from the european union to conduct
reforms
to
to strengthen democracy and it will give
also
new expertise to ukraine will give the
european union a possibility to send
more experts to ukraine to help it
become a member of the european union
one day
roman thank you very much that was dw's
roman goncharenko in kiev
so today the european commission will
issue its recommendation on ukraine's
application for eu membership but the
final decision on that status rests with
the leaders of the eu member states
themselves who meet for a council summit
next week the commission is expected to
recommend candidacy status for ukraine
and neighboring moldova
but there's a host of other states
who've been waiting for years to join
the eu here in dark blue notably turkey
and countries in the western balkans
well for more let's cross over to our
brussels bureau chief alexandre from
alexander tell us more about the
recommendation that the commission is
expected to issue today
well indeed terry we expect the european
commission to recommend that ukraine and
by the way moldova as well be granted
candidate status however it will be
interesting to see how they are going to
express
this opinion because we know that the
decision about that was postponed a
couple of times because of course it's
not an easy decision and some officials
are saying that it's
ukraine has a lot
to do still they have to fight
corruption they have to do more to
improve the rule of law situation in the
country and nevertheless we expect the
european commission to make this
recommendation today especially of
course now after france italy and
germany threw their weight behind this
idea however when it happens today it
could be that this decision will be
connected
with conditions and
of course it will be only the beginning
of a very long process let's have a look
at our explainer
ukraine may be on its way into the
european union
and some leaders have promised it won't
take long
it will be
not as usual a matter of years to form
this opinion but i think a matter of
weeks if we work closely together
so for you
thank you
but despite the public show of
solidarity the eu commission president
displayed here on her first visit to
ukraine there are a few legal challenges
ahead
candidacy is the first step countries
have to fulfill the so-called copenhagen
criteria which includes having a stable
democratic government
that applies the rule of law
the second stage are accession talks
which mark the beginning of practical
preparations for eu membership so a
country would usually need to undergo a
reform process which includes its
judiciary the administration its economy
and political structures
the rules add up to 35 chapters in total
with long lists of conditions countries
are vetted accordingly by the commission
on the state of their markets
agriculture external relations and other
factors
if eu negotiators find a problem like
government meddling in the appointment
of judges they can demand justice
reforms which can take years
finland needed three years to comply
turkey started the negotiating phase
back in 2005 but talks have long been
deadlocked due to ankara's increasingly
authoritarian tendencies and the
leadership's unwillingness to reform and
in the case of ukraine the french
president seems to have low expectations
we all know perfectly well that the
process allowing them to join will take
several years in truth probably several
decades
[Music]
[Applause]
once all 35 chapters of requirements are
satisfied and all member states have
signed off on them together with the
european commission and the european
parliament an accession treaty is put
forward it is then signed and ratified
and voila you are a eu member states
in the mid 2000s 12 mostly eastern
european countries were allowed to join
the bloc
despite apparent issues with
dysfunctional institutions and
deep-seated corruption
the understanding was that for former
communist countries change was more
difficult to bring about
a political decision was made
ukraine today has institutional issues
as well
on top of that it will need massive
reconstruction efforts after the war
and it seems that at the moment not
everyone in the eu is motivated to take
them in
so the path to eu membership can be long
and difficult
and some members do oppose membership
for ukraine some of the eu member states
now alexander tell us more about that
yeah we're talking about states uh such
as portugal for instance or denmark or
the never lands they are saying that
it's not the right thing to to to grant
ukraine a
status because the country is at war any
accession talks could only begin after
the war is over they are also saying
that it would be not fair to
for ukraine to jump the queue
when we consider that are that they are
there are other states such as
montenegro north macedonia for instance
who have been in the waiting room for
years even though they are official
candidate states and there are also
voices saying that
the european union itself is not ready
to welcome new members because
before that they need to reform the bloc
so as you see there are some member
states who are very skeptical and of
course to grant ukraine
in eu
candidate status we would need all the
member states the eu would need all the
member states to be on board
alexander thank you very much as always
our brussels bureau chief alex sandra
from naman
you